hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today we're
gonna be going over a game from wang hao
against a nice giri wang hao of course
is going to be in the candidates this
year canada's tournament coming up in
march here might have already started by
the time this video airs and so i wanted
to take a look at some of his best games
against the world's top players who he
will be facing later in march so this
was a game he had against Anish gary and
it started with d4 d6 then i've been
reading my youtube comments they say all
i go over is d4 games so I tricked you
this one actually an e4 game it was an
e4 game all along
you just never realized it Knight f6 was
played Knight c3 and then black
continues with E 5 and we have a
Philidor type position up here it's type
of position whatever you want to call it
white continues with Knight f3 simple
development developing the Knights
supporting his center black continues
with Knight bd7
white comes up with Bishop c4 and now
black actually goes in for a little bit
of a sideline here generally black plays
Bishop e7 white gets castled and black
gets castled and you have a normal sort
of efore a5 Philidor type of game in
this case though black takes on d4
instead of playing Bishop e7 and now you
have probably been told time and time
again that in the opening you're not
supposed to get your queen out too early
because it's likely gonna get harassed
by black's pieces and you're going to
lose time and your opponent is going to
use that time to get developed in this
case though it actually makes a lot of
sense to take this pawn back with the
Queen and the reason for this is both
this bishop and this knight are in poor
position to actually threaten this Queen
now you can imagine if this Knight were
back on b8 it would come out to c6 and
hid whites Queen and develop with tempo
but unfortunately for black he's already
committed this this Knight to the two
he's already committed this Knight to
the d7 square where it cannot attack
this
and so the result of that is the Queen
on d4 is simply a strong active piece
that isn't really vulnerable to this
type of harassment black continues
development with Bishop e7 and now white
actually has a few options here you can
still just play a normal chess game just
get castled develop your bishop anything
like that but what wang how to chooses
to do is very very interesting and that
move is Bishop takes f7 a sacrifice
early on in the opening taking advantage
of the fact that his queen has already
been activated
he's already developed at these pieces
and he has easy development with this
Bishop ready to attack the King side as
well
black plays the only move black can
really play with King takes f7 and now
Knight g5 check comes on the board and
this check is actually pretty annoying
to deal with if you come back to f8
obviously you're gonna get hit with a
fork if you come back to g8 the problem
is going to be this active Queen and it
comes to the c-4 square and there's no
good way to deal with this check and you
can block momentarily but I'll simply
take and these threats aren't going away
of course you don't really want to come
to g6 you're just a little bit too
vulnerable out in front of your own
pawns like that and that leaves one move
King e8 and now you might be thinking to
yourself well you know we've seen you
know it's what what's it called why
can't I think of it what's it called
Danny what's it called when you
checkmate a king with a knight
suffocation smothered mate alright we'll
cut that up now you've seen smothered
mates before happened to a king but in
this case it's pretty interesting it
actually happens to Black's Queen here
but this is still the line that we see
occur in the game and now black actually
does have a way to save the queen he
does so with this move c5 he responds to
the threat to his own queen by attacking
whites Queen and giving his own queen
squares to escape
of course white isn't interested in a
Korean trade so he simply retreats this
Queen back to d1 and this force is black
now to spend a move saving his own queen
and now white is able to break through
with this move Knight takes g7 check of
course the King has to move again it's
best in this case not to go to d8 where
it could get a little stuck and would
risk would be a harassed by more checks
instead it's better to come out to f7
gain some more time on this night so the
knight has to move again in this case
back to f5 this Bishop drops back to f8
supporting some of these squares
preventing things like Knight h6 check
and stepping out of the threat of
capture as well and white takes this
opportunity to simply castle and now
we've reached a point in the game where
black has kind of dealt with the
immediate sacrifices and the immediate
threats from white you know he's left
with this King on f7 but for the moment
he is solidly up a piece and now is the
point where he has to make decisions and
honestly this is the difficult part of
of this opening here for these top
players that can usually calculate well
enough to deal with all of the forcing
variations so black survived the forcing
variations but it's actually at this
moment where he makes a critical mistake
now this has been analyzed in more depth
since this game that happened back in
2013 and these days players have kind of
realized that rook g8 is the way to go
for black here you can put some pressure
on White's King's side and activate this
rook simultaneously guarding some
squares in front of the black King this
is what players have been playing that
these days now over the board it's gonna
be very difficult to figure out that
rich Jade is the best move because black
simply has too many options here you can
play and move like Queen c6 or it can
play move like d5 which is what a nice
Giri played in the game unfortunately
for him this one doesn't work out so
well Knight takes d5 from long how Geary
recaptures this Knight with Knight takes
d5 and now simply Queen takes d5 check
is hitting this King now actually here
yuria makes another critical mistake
already white might have some slight
pressure some slight pull in this
position but Queenie six would keep the
game going white could drop back all the
way to d1 aiming at some squares on this
Queen side such as h5 but after rook g8
like might still be doing okay instead
though in the game we saw a niche Gary
bring this King back to e8 and this
allows white to bring his final
attacking minor piece into the game with
Bishop g5 guarding all of the squares
around the black king
Anish tried Queen g6 to put some
pressure on this piece but Wang Cao
simply ignores this threat because it's
not a threat and with Roc ad one of
course you can't capture this bishop due
to Knight d6 check winning the Queen
Gary now try droid g8 making this a real
threat but Wang Cao simply plays f4
defending this bishop and putting more
pieces in powerful attacking position
here you see white just dominates the
center of the board dominates with his
attacking pieces and the black pieces
are stuck in the first two ranks not
doing much at all a5 was what a nice
Gary tried but of course this doesn't
get the job done perhaps he wanted to do
some lateral defense with this rook but
it's too little too late
Wang Chao plays d5 a nice move taking
advantage of this d6 square even more
Gary tried taking this Knight of course
this leaves the defense of the rook
behind so long house simply captures and
now Rick a6 does come on the board but
it's much too little much too late rook
e1 from Long how rook g6 and now the
final move of the game wang hao ignores
the threat to his queen and simply plays
d6 and this is where a nice giri decided
to resign of course if rook takes g8 you
would simply see II takes d7 check King
f7 and then white gets a a brand new
Queen for his troubles so a very nice
game from Wang Hao a nice attacking game
a sacrificial game to take out a nice
giri whom he will be facing later on in
march in the candidates tournament so I
wish wang hao the best of luck he's
definitely one of the underdogs and
coming candidates tournament but I think
a Wong have magnus carlsen World
Championship match would be one for the
ages
so best of luck to wong hau in this
candidates tournament coming up and
thank you so much for joining me on this
week's episode of the review my name is
Caleb Denby and I'll see you next time